vient de s'excuser aujourd'hui on se
retrouve dans mon bureau totalement vide
c'est un loyer je suis un ouvrier ou non
exactement c'est gentil on y va allez tu
sais lequel fait quoi non c'est une
poupée carton ce qui est incroyable avec
l'original j'obtiens petit garçon
parlement de séduire la mafia et état
devant de l'outil de kalmoukie âge
raconte d'accord suis déçu le système
est à l'ombre en ballon de cet outillage
que j'ai acheté des pièces cassées
je veux juste être remboursés du meuble
c'est ce qu'on a le hyper importante
je signe à pasaia me tiens maintenant on
va mettre les dents 3 on va faire un peu
comme papa sa maman je t'aime maman je
tiens ma part je pense à rien je peux
juste le décalé sans rien sur 100
ouvriers et briller un bug
the waiting to batteur vu qu'ils aillent
vers ceux de poche c'est un placement
produit tarascon votch oh là là mais ils
ont raison c'est le meilleur création de
produits jaune parce que je sais que tu
es tout les internautes de suivre a dit
m jouer le jeu elle est belle séverine
on veut juste vrai rôle à tenir en cours
on en cas d'exercice gt3 wayne fowkes
cette liste mais c'était l'islam et
quads expérience ça peut être fait le
bistrot est passionnant parce que tu
dois y est la puissance sur les persos
poche les bruits que je veux qu'il
allait ferait tuer le président par
contre c'est toujours un peu
je vous présente le bureau de squeeze
way avec la perceuse bosse toujours ta
gueule pendant ce grand prix du kg à
tort de la juste un mec de 13 ans ouais
merde c'est le premier mot % soir un
sénégalais sont les anglais la vidéo
j'ai un truc qui passent regardent
on passe à l'étagé en dessous du fg
radio fg en six ans
je vous passe la bosch et ça je le vois
la perche de bâches la place où les
bègues comme si on vote avec la perceuse
bosch la côte d'ivoire pour le technique
on n'a plus les rails qui se met là et
qui tiennent les planches mois alors
qu'il ya déjà un voleur de deux bouts de
métal réputé alors il a buté dans la
réalité on va ce qu'il y aura donc chez
lacroix qui fait des blagues nulles à la
fois ma foi de nos personnages et des
petites là parce que je m'attendais à
thaksin
sabine lagadec bis rue avec 15 ou alors
est amené l'état gère la bibliothèque
suaire l'avant fier de mon gars ça c'est
son prêt ce qu'on peut au revoir
je suis très dénudée sur la chaîne de
squeeze oh mon dieu au revoir aux
citoyens les enfants au mois obama
l'agencé de la fin de cette vidéo
ce montage de danse 1 3 heures et ont
monté deux petits meubles
je vais finir tout ça dans votre projet
merci à vous regarder cette de montage
de meubles voilà je fasse ça a été fait
on vient de créer un concept monter les
meubles en vidéo c'est pas du tout
passionnant merci d'avoir regardé portez
vous bien justement mon fils